Matt, what are you doing? Crafts?
>> no, I'm actually working on a demonstration for random selection.
I have selected some beads to represent the people. And I have
three different colors. Red, white and blue representing a single trait.
But I have three different versions: the red, white and blue version.
>> But why did you put them in the bottle?
>> Well, the bottle is representative of
the whole population of people living in a
region, for example. We have roughly equal
frequencies of all the colors in our population,
though there's a slight increase in the number of
red individuals living at this sort of top of
the bottle. Now, for this representative of random selection,
we need an event to happen that's completely random.
>> How about a meteor?
>> A meteor, that sounds great. So a meteor strike
is coming to earth, and it comes in this region and.
Now notice what happened, is all these people, oops a couple
are still trying to survive there. Everybody that survived ran away
and got away from the meteor. And those that weren't able
to run fast enough stayed in the bottle, and unfortunately they
didn't survive. And so, the people who survive were able to
run away due to the glass dish, and those that couldn't,
still here in the, in the bottle. Unfortunately these didn't survive.
And what I want you to notice, if we see here,
is that, tell me the frequency difference between the
individuals in the bottle and those in the glass dish.
>> Well, it looks like most of the red
survived, but not as many blue and white beads did.
>> Exactly, and that's because there was a change
in the allelic frequency due to a random selection event.
>> Oh, the bottleneck effect.
>> Exactly. You can see here we represented that quite literally.
And so, those in the bottle didn't survive,
we changed the allelic frequency. More red in the
dish, those that survive. And now we have
a change that resulted from a completely random event.